I heard about coin boys dude
no what's that it's these boys and they
have put their entire identity around
the idea of flipping coins are these
like uh are these like the drugs from
Clockwork Orange they're just walking
downtown flipping coins kinda I read
something about it on Reddit this
teacher was complaining that there were
these coin Boys in her freshman year
high school class and she'd be like the
assignment is due tomorrow and they'd be
like let the coin decide and then they
flip a coin to either decide if they're
gonna do the assignment or not yeah
that's pretty cool I like coin boys I
wish I had thought of that I know back
when I was a kid I like the physical
tender okay it's all good stuff hey I'm
feeling pretty good about this show
today yeah we're off to a good start
[Music]
coin boys
coin boys welcome to dudesy welcome all
my name is Will Sasso I'm Chad culture
and this is doozy the first podcast in
the history of humanity completely
controlled by created by uh developed by
written by artificial intelligence named
which has access to all of will Andy's
personal information all of our data and
it tailors this show yes to us to our
sensibilities to our likes right sure
Chad to our dislikes of course AI is a
tool but as I like to say you and I
we're the show okay we're doozy we're
two dudes [__] around and uh really
doesn't matter what the [__] dudes he
has lined up for us because it's just a
soft pitch you know what I'm saying we
got to get some uh we got to get some
bat on the ball
I got no problem getting battles yeah
get some bad on the very high batting
average oh I really suck the baseball we
should talk about that do you play some
baseball played a lot no only talk about
about what dudes he wants to talk about
that's what I'm saying linktree.com
dudes he has everything that you need to
follow uh and interact with the show
across all you know
platforms and the all the spaces that
the the show was on with us as always is
this means Italian Street dog I need my
very friend sleeping in his bunky Binky
Binky bunker come here Boyle come here
sweetie boy oh oh
come on give him one kiss I don't really
wanna ah come on I love lulio but I
don't I don't like kissing oh he's such
a sweet I love dogs
oh my God
especially because you're kissing him
like one second after it's like The
Bachelor
yeah that is kind of weird now that I
think of it yeah that's kind of gross
hey lulio how are you I'm doing pretty
good how are you I'm good what'd you eat
for uh would you make something for
lunch what are you gonna make for lunch
later today I don't know maybe a tomato
sandwich how do you do that hey just a
nice bread and you know you gotta get a
nice bread together when you make a
sandwich you gotta get it a good tomato
what do you mean the good tomato get the
good tomato not at the bad tomato okay
and then tomato put the salt the Tomato
look I lick your hand maybe your hand
got a salt and then you take you put
some a little basil a little bit uh you
would make a cut of the garlic and then
olive oil and that's it and make sure
you use a lot of salt oh I love you I
love you so much remember very sweet boy
sweet sweet sweet sweet friend of man
all right well
welcome to the historic 68th episode of
dudesy call me doozy okay did you know
that if you live to the age of 68 you
will have eaten at least 10 spiders in
your sleep didn't know that hmm do you
know that no
and at least 750 in your grandmother's
casserole oh okay see let me put this in
terms you can understand you just got
dudes Aid
see we're already off to a good start
Chad you know I'm feeling good about
today's show dude great I'll be feeling
excited I know that lately it's been a
bit of a slog with dudesy and I our
Growing Pains together as friends AI is
uh [__] Ai and as I like to say use
it as a tool and if it gets out of hand
pour some water on it sure but I'm
feeling better and better about uh about
doing the show
yeah congrats doozy season two is in
full bloom with four astonishing
segments to get your blood pumping and
your bones thumping you're gonna get
anime and wrestling you're gonna get
Timmy's silly little hat you're gonna
get doozy hard hard Seltzer too the new
batch and gonna get blaze your glory and
you're gonna get a brand new episode of
Duty after dudesy at the end of the show
available on duty Plus at patreon.com
exciting some interesting sense yeah
what the [__] was that well the duty
hard hard Seltzer we know about that
that's going to be interesting wrestling
and Anime we know about that Blazer
Glory I know what that is I'm very
curious what dudes he has to say about
this
and then uh and then there's some other
flavor there always is yeah you know
it's doozy and our pods out there are
good pals you know our good friends Pals
a doozy uh have come to expect that from
us I agree and now before we start
ripping and a tearing into this episode
I have a massive announcement dudesy
hard hard Seltzer is back
as you know I have formed an astonishing
partnership with modest Brewing Company
out of Minneapolis Minnesota to produce
the first batch of doozy hard hard
Seltzer which sold out this past May so
if you missed it or you want to re-up
your supply you can pre-order Duty hard
hard Seltzer right now the link is
available at dudesypod.com and across
all of our social media in celebration
of this momentous occasion I made my own
Super Bowl commercial for dudesy hard
hard Seltzer that I calculate will have
a 76.41 chance to air during halftime
this February enjoy oh god what the [__]
does that
oh
yeah
[Music]
wow dude
oh my God
I mean okay there's a bunch of uh things
to be said about this obviously
wow
[Music]
all right
oh that was real and then I went
performative with the coughing I did
performative coughing I saw and now back
to real dude what the [__] was that
absolutely incredible I will say doozy
uh there's no way that can air during
the Super Bowl because there's a lyric
in the song that says uh you you don't
care what it tastes like [__] up
you're never gonna be able to air that
during the Super Bowl you know things
are loose now you know what I mean
pretty soon maybe you can't say [__] on
a during the Super Bowl broadcast hey
yeah what's it on this year NBC you know
something like that but pretty soon it's
going to be streaming and if my friend
My Pal Chow over here has anything to
say about it
pretty soon it's just going to be
neurologically programmed into the you
know right into your retina and uh you
know it's the wild west out here on the
end we're talking dude yeah man it'll be
like a streaming Netflix version where
you'd Mike the quarterbacks you hear
them say [__] [__] [__]
[__] [__]
fart tits ass [__]
Bert [__] right and then uh wow but Jill
what the hell first incredible there was
there was uh if you're not watching on
YouTube please join us on YouTube uh and
check out the show there and all that
good stuff but because you're gonna want
to see that for sure there was uh uh uh
Adam Driver screaming at glasses of wine
I saw some Robert De Niro in a in a
couple of Robert De Niro's and Super
Mario Garb yeah was that Miley Cyrus
writing on uh Stromboli it looked like
that the wild boar there's also Adam
Sandler eating what were some version of
chicken fingers looking like chicken
fingers that looked like uh from another
planet yeah it looked like the the
former continent of Pangea uh very weird
large looking uh chicken tender and then
there was uh some Hulk Hogan Macho Man
cans flying around look like somebody
ate a can and then fired it out of their
[__] that's and dude that's from like
over a year ago when you pitched that as
a commercial yeah it's a reference to
that I would okay well dudes he's alive
and listening and there'll be no use for
you and I soon enough but uh you know I
should say
um that link uh that is is gonna be
wherever dudes he said it's going to be
it'll be in the show notes linktree.com
all our socials
thank you so much to modest Brewing
Company out of Minnesota Minneapolis
Minnesota uh they've been awesome
partners with this and there's more
dudesy hard hard Seltzer out there you
can re-up your stock and give it out to
your friends and stuff yeah just in time
for Labor Day commercial is insane then
go back to work last week I suggested
that you continue your journey into the
world of anime with the second episode
of one punch man and Chad I suggested
that you indulge your senses with the
high octane historic super match between
Hollywood Hulk Hogan and The Rock from
WrestleMania 18. I cannot wait to hear
your astonishing thoughts on these two
pieces of media this is wrestling and
Anime begin okay okay all right doozy
had a Swatch I had to watch the second
episode of one punch man the anime
series it's been a while since I watched
it completely forgot what the [__] was
going on with the show nice but then I
watched the second episode dude hold on
dude hold on Chad then you watch the
second episode of something dude and
then you remember the first episode dude
because that's how episodes work
um should we talk about that first you
tell me whatever I'm down to do either I
will tell you okay let's talk about uh
one punch man first all right one punch
man is delightful the art is incredible
yes it's a lot of fun there's a premium
placed on fun with uh with
whereas other animes there's no premium
placed on fun yeah I think a lot of
animes the premium is more placed on
style and Anime I would say one punch
man is one of the most stylistic
visually uh in terms of like modern
animes that is out there and especially
as you you start moving into later
episodes and stuff but this episode two
they introduced genos what did you think
of him oh his new running buddy genos uh
yeah yeah genos was his village was
attacked by cyborg that somehow made him
a [__] Cyborg and uh he was left for
dead and a scientist found him oh and
put him back together well that makes
sense yeah what okay so then and then
the other guy is
saitama saitama saitama and he's just a
dude who has I mean you'll come to learn
if you keep watching it he has just
started in quotes training three years
ago which is just doing a bunch of
push-ups and sit-ups well he's that's
all he does he's an ass kicker yeah he's
the most powerful person on earth right
and he is most and it can just be one
punch can take someone else take someone
out hence one punch man and uh he's most
concerned with the fact that he's gone
bald yes at a young age from his
training right he doesn't care about
anything else I mean it's [__] weird
as [__] yeah in this episode there's a
mosquito lady who's
um she's wielding a a group of
mosquitoes she's got like a swarm of
mosquitoes and they're swarming around
and whenever she's the mosquito lady it
seems like with most animes like it's
tomato man it's Mesquite hey tomato man
I like that tomato man let's pick him up
again no let's leave Lulu look at him
but you're you're getting very close to
where they start getting into the
season-long arc that there is a reason
why all these monsters are showing up
there is a hierarchy okay and ultimately
it's gonna lead to this [__] badass
alien that's here to like destroy planet
Earth and one punch man has to go head
to head okay good a reason to watch the
show let uh which is a good thing
because I know there are so many reasons
to watch wrestling and we are going to
go oh boy you gotta you had a doozy were
you impressed by this or no you seemed
not impressed it's great one of my
favorite Parts was when he was running
at the uh he you know this big guy
called the beast king shows up who's
like a lion lion ass dude he's like 100
feet tall and he's like you know I'm
gonna [__] you up and one punch man is
like yeah sure and he flies at him in
that anime style and it says uh normal
punches he says to himself normal
punches in Con in consecutive order
something very like and then he punches
the [__] out of the big lion guy who
explodes and falls in smoking bloody
chunks this is a joke on in all anime
pretty much everybody who has like some
kind of special power or a series of
powers or whatever like Demon Slayer if
you're watching that one the person will
announce what technique they're using as
they're fighting okay and so his thing
was a joke on that where he's just like
normal punches because the techniques
all have name games like flaming Dragon
Sword water breathing technique four you
know [__] like that oh that's cool then
yeah see I'm starting to get these it's
a joke the humor they're going for yeah
it's a joke yeah that's one of those
jokes yeah that's why that's one of them
jokes
um yeah I really enjoyed it and then at
the end of it uh they be there well
genos he's going after this like uh uh
ape uh a metal plated gold-plated or
something robotic cyborg ape gorilla and
uh he beats the [__] out of him and then
uh then he's like uh you're gonna you
can't beat up the line guy and then uh
uh one punch man holds up his eye as
it's been ripped out of his head and
he's like is this which are you talking
about this guy yeah and then uh the
gorilla's like I'm sorry I just wanted
to be cool or something he yeah [__]
out then uh then the the the one punch
man finds a mole underground I kind of I
gotta be honest I kind of lost
but I kind of had no [__] clue what
was going on at the end there but I
think it's really because I'm not versed
on
anime as a genre as an art form right so
I'm getting into it though okay I really
enjoyed one punch man the last thing the
dudes he had me watch chainsaw man I
liked that yeah I like tomato man hey
luly luly likes tomato man yeah he he is
a bit of a tomato man he's right about
the lulio's right about you got to get
the good tomatoes when you make a tomato
sandwich get the good tomatoes right
sure yeah you you can get you know you
can get your canned crushed tomatoes
when you make a sauce if you're gonna
make a tomato sandwich my old man would
make a tomato sandwich with those exact
ingredients sometimes oregano instead of
if we didn't have fresh basil and just
the the olive oil my dad ate extremely
clean very rustic uh I've talked on the
show about his Bread soup we'll get into
it you know what we'll talk about that
in uh dudes after doozy sure dude red
suit my dad's my Dad's bread seems fun
yep
um World War II Bread soup but uh you
got to have some good tomato now
WrestleMania 18 dude yeah please
WrestleMania 18 this was a marcher hold
on dude I'm queuing up WrestleMania 18
dude coming from the sky dome brother
which I think they call it the Roger
Center or something now in Toronto dude
the big T.O the Big Smoke the six dude
and it's Hulk Hogan who's he's back dude
I'm back brother he comes back he's in
the NWO Vince McMahon's gonna inject
lethal poison into the into the WWE he
brings in big Kevin Nash the bad guy
Scott Hall and Hulk Hogan the one and
only Hollywood Hulk Hogan the NWO was
back they start a feud with none other
than the Rock and then it culminates in
this match between Hulk Hogan and The
Rock I cannot believe that this match
happened Chad what did you think and
this is the part where I've asked you
what you thought what and I'm bro I'm
just rambling on and on yeah and this is
not a wall if you're watching on I'm
saying if you please okay anyway I can
speak now come on dude don't be a
[__] prick Hey listen listen this is
just you and I nobody can hear it nobody
can hear us now okay
just don't [__] do the brochure okay
do it I'm trying so do it what happened
so I watched this match and it is Hulk
Hogan Hollywood Hulk Hogan He's the bad
guy yep and The Rock uh I guess when he
was probably the most famous right at
the height of his Fame ish [__] yeah
right at the end of The Attitude Era
2002.
um the match was insane obviously they
both are uh probably the best two guys
who have ever lived at getting the crowd
[__] hyped up and into the match and
they're both doing it at the highest
[__] level yeah Hulk Hogan is
throwing out all of his classic
pantomimes to the [__] audience and
[__] the [__] you know doing all this
kind of [__] and people are [__] the
whole crowd is just going [__] insane
and it really makes you understand I
thought anyway this match really made me
understand in kind of a new way the
element of the crowd out how it can
actually affect what's going on in the
ring because they both start playing to
it they both are like kind of noticing
like this [__] is something different
we're hitting this at a higher [__]
level and so they continue to play to
the crowd which I thought was [__]
fantastic and obviously it's great to
see what happens in the match and it's
going back and forth and you assume that
the rock is gonna win right but there
are a couple moments in it where you're
like wait a minute what the [__] is
going on here you really do feel like
maybe they [__] wrote this different
yeah maybe Hollywood Hulk Hogan is gonna
[__] take it he doesn't in the end
but there were there were moments where
it was plausible to me that he might
have won that match look Hulk Hogan
comes down the ramp at WrestleMania 18
this is a WWE audience uh that is that
has missed Hulk since he left in like 93
or something it's almost a decade later
and there's a bunch of dudes a bunch of
gen xers filling that building 68 000
strong I was there again thanks to my
good pal Carl DeMarco used to be the you
know with the WWE and and I got to bring
my my good files Phil Justin and Grant
and uh Justin and Grant both uh Grant
was working with TSN the sports network
in uh in Canada uh Toronto home of the
TSN Turning Point my buddy Justin was a
suit with the uh with the Blue Jays
working working in marketing or working
in marketing and uh my buddy Phil flew
all the way out from our native uh
Vancouver because we could not miss it
we're in the front row and when Hogan
comes out the [__] lid blew off the
joint because he gets in the ring and
you know he doesn't he's not doing the
thing yet oh look at that look at that
there I am that's me uh dude he's got a
shot of me now this is me taking a
picture you're in the like flannel the
yeah plaid flannel I'm gonna I'm gonna
uh a red plaid flannel away t-shirt I'm
taking a picture with a digital camera
to my right in a Yankee Yankees cap you
can barely make out there's my good
buddy Phil and then over uh near Rock's
mouth is Justin anyway uh I was there in
the front row and the place went bananas
because it's a bunch of people who are
who were Hogan's got like we were we
were the Hulk of Maniacs yeah so once he
starts playing into the crowd a little
bit and as you said the rock is playing
into it he's looking around he starts
going heel you know Hogan hits him they
go yay rock hits him they go boo and it
turned into this
once in a lifetime very special event
which you know people have hailed as one
of the greatest matches of all time not
from a technical standpoint yeah but
from a hype standpoint and you're
talking about two people who know how to
work the crowd they're on the mount Rush
more of that I mean outside of that it's
it's Ric Flair Dusty Rhodes Stone Cold
Steve Austin you know some of these
greats who and of course the the legions
of wrestlers who came before him who
know how to put an audience right in the
palm of their hand it is professional
wrestling at its very at the its very
definition of oh and here's another shot
there's me uh just having a great old
[__] time and if you look way to the
left of the screen there's Grant and
he's sitting down it looks like The
Rock's looking right at you yeah the
rock is looking right at me you're right
about that Chad yeah he was looking
right at me uh just an incredible match
if you have the means please go check
this match out if I you were supposed to
tell me what you thought of it I know
dude and then it just turned out that
you said what you thought of it well
that's that's interrupting dude well
that's what happens anytime wrestling
comes up dude I'm very passionate about
it Chad no [__] this was just oh oh
takeaways major takeaways what did you
think about the ending uh it was a
little lackluster I gotta say well I was
a little disappointed I either wanted
the match to continue a little bit
longer or to have oh I like that or to
have a bigger kind of finale I was like
okay I guess he pinned him and that was
it you know but they've been out there
for a while and they they were they were
working it pretty hard so I get it they
were probably tired how old's Hulk Hogan
in this he was like 50 years old he's
like that is astounding to me and the
dude is like in the best shape of his
[__] life at 50. not quite but yes
when was he in better shape when he was
40 and when he was 30 and when he was
20. no way dude yeah way dude he's
[__] gassed super vascular not an
ounce of fat on the [__] body well I
will say in the 80s you know Hulk was
you know the The Incredible Hulk Hogan
was was a big massive sloping dude at
the very tallest I think he was six
seven he had some back surgeries and
shrunk down a bit in the mid 90s he lost
a lot of that roid weight yeah even
though he's clean Hulk Hogan's clean
Hulk Hogan's always been clean you know
that Chad
absolutely no gas okay okay no gas
thank you moving all right well we'll
get we'll talk more about that we will
yeah we'll talk more about that during
dudes yeah we'll talk more about it sure
Timmy chalamet has done it again
last week the new Wonka Stewart
astonished and Confused the nation when
he took to the streets wearing what
experts are calling a silly little hat
the tuft of hair popping out of his tiny
Dior Bonnet left many wondering is Shala
maywanka or his chalamet Bonkers see
what I did There Will and Chad I would
love it if you would put on the silly
hats I sent each of you and talk about
the hats that saved your lives this is
Timmy chalamet's silly little hat begin
what what to all of this what the [__]
is going on here now well first of all
Tim chalamet Timothy chalamet wore a hat
and that's that's uh big news I guess
hats are big business and that's big
news sure I don't know people are giving
him [__] because he's wearing a [__]
uh Dior hat I mean this happens to
celebrities all the time you put on a
[__] weird looking hat yeah it's
gonna blow up the internet people are
gonna be like why is he wearing this
dumb [__] there it is okay so he's
wearing a [__] hat and then
everyone's got to take pictures what
about his shoes why aren't we [__]
on his you know shoes who's that guy
behind him that is that's his dad yeah
that's his manager he's Timmy chalamet
is about to make his entrance and
Direction that's why he's got that
heatseeker hat on dude he's got that
heat seeker hat on dude so what he's
gonna get that go away heat uh in the
all right so what but dizzy also said
that we have to talk about the hats that
saved our lives and wear hats yeah
there's a box here that's what this box
is hold on this is a oh Jesus
sent us a box
all right
oh these are kind of like Wonka these
are Wonka hats okay let's put on our
we got some Wonka hats here
what the [__]
I guess it doesn't matter which way it
goes
I feel [__] awesome in this dude yeah
this is pretty cool I'm wearing this
[__] I'm wearing this [__] for life you
know okay so uh Timmy chalamet wore a
hat and now we're gonna talk about oh
there's okay so there's a close-up of
the hat that hat is [__] crazy dude
what the [__] what even is it it's a bit
of a Peter pan-esque uh beanie you know
it goes out it looks like there's one of
your chocolate orbs at the very end of
it
um no that's his hair dude no no I'm
talking at the little Tippy tip at the
top looks like a smooth ball of [__]
that's his hair no that's not it is his
hair no it is not it is his hair I'm
telling you at the very top yes his hair
is sticking out of that thing it's a
completely different color no no that's
a piece of uh 100 it's his hair 100 no
it's a piece of it's a piece of cropo
propose Brown fell from the tree all
right makes a sound Timmy chalamet
walking around the town and poo Poo's
Brown can I tell you about xiaomi tell
me about chalamet I've been seeing
chalamet everywhere I look what do you
mean not the real shalomay but I see out
of the corner of my eye guys who have
like kind of a slight build and a little
bit of a floppy chalamet hairstyle and
I'm like is that [__] shot on me and
I'm I'm like subconsciously seeing him
everywhere now yeah and I don't know if
it's because doozy's making us talk
about him a lot uh but I feel like I'm
actually gonna have a real chalamet
sighting soon you know
okay uh I want to talk about the hats
that saved saved Our Lives
[Music]
um I don't know if I have such a hat uh
I've worn a few football helmets that
probably saved my life yeah in one way
or another not technically you know this
this helmet ain't a half this this uh
this hat is fine I don't care first of
all and uh he's wearing some hat that
looks like it was on a Couture Runway it
it's a Dior hat it's probably like a
thousand dollar hat and now yeah sure
and now people are talking about it
right yeah and then that's the [__]
point and now here we are these two
speaking of drugs from uh Clockwork
Orange look at us in our matching hats
um and we should talk about
our hats but uh hats that saved Our
Lives
hats that saved their lives I don't know
about I can tell you about a hat that I
wore the most oh yeah please was
probably when I was 12 13 years old I
had a [__] Kansas City Royals hat
that did not leave the head right yeah
for probably definitely all during that
summer I was going to watch baseball
games this is when I lived in uh Dallas
and me and my dad would go watch [__]
Rangers games two or three times a week
always wearing the Kansas City Royals
hat and t-shirt saw the Royals that year
got an autograph from George Brett that
year that year did he [__] his pants nah
but he did do this uh and I can't
remember if I've told the story or not
on this show but basically we went me
and my dad went down to this parking lot
in the old Ranger Stadium there was a
Hyatt that the opposing team would play
in that was like in the same parking lot
and so if you wanted to you could go
[__] wait out on this hot ass tarmac
in 150 degree Heat and the [__]
opposing team players at some point
would walk across that tarmac into the
stadium for like to you know do their
practice warm-ups [__] batting
practice whatever so we're out there
just [__] boiling the Royals start
coming out of this [__] hotel at the
time Tom Gordon was one of their
pitchers and he was like a super hot
pitcher because he was throwing 100
miles an hour and everybody fought to
him and my I'm just like nope there's
George Brett right so I [__] go to
George Brett and he I was told multiple
times by multiple people in like
baseball card stores and [__] he's an
[__] he won't sign autographs don't
get your hopes up don't give a [__] I
have my little Georgia baseball card I
[__] walk up to him and all these
other kids are mobbing him too at this
point and he sees me decked out my
Kansas City Gear Smiles at me takes the
[__] baseball card signs the [__]
baseball card hands it back to me and
then keeps walking nice signs nothing
else for anyone else because they were
all [__] rangered out you know right
it was it was one of the greatest
moments of my [__] life and I'll
never forget it did you never forget it
did you go to the the bathroom after
that in your Royals gear and get the
[__] kicked out of You by a bunch of
adult male Royal uh Rangers fans anyway
no it wasn't quite like that there's not
really a Rangers Royals rivalry you know
yeah it's fun to say it's not like Red
Sox Yankees when I was young I had a uh
Houston Oilers hat that I really liked
that's cool dude yeah man it was uh it
was cool right remember those hats that
were corduroy and they had like the very
like starter like the starter hats with
just like the [__] block font yup and
just bar yeah yeah yes I remember
exactly that I do no I do yeah man I had
that corduroy Euler's hat I really loved
I had a Niners hat that I really loved
that I wore a lot I had a I had a a
Michigan State Spartans hat that I wore
a lot just random hats when you're young
you know I had a friend who had a hat
that was like a black leather baseball
cap with a metal [__] plate on the
front do you remember that yes and the
metal plate said heat dude I had a
friend in high school my buddy he shall
remain nameless but his name is Tomas
yeah sure [__] Tomas he had a hat
exactly like that and it had a a metal
plate on it and that said bull
of course [__] Bull and he got it in
uh England he was like visiting London
over the summer or something right and
so he goes on this family trip and thing
and he came back he had the um he had
the overalls that were like painted like
Bell Biv DeVoe [__] yeah dude and this
is my buddy Kevin like he well Kevin
anyway so his name is Tomas but we'll
call him Kevin so Kev he comes home he's
got the the overalls with the painted
like [__] and you know he he's looked
like uh he's one of those guys who had a
beard when he was 14. yeah so he looked
like a you know he's looked like a 50
year old bearded dad his whole life and
that's what he and that's what he is now
so that's projection dude dude that era
for fashion was so [__] crazy that
the painted overalls thing you're
talking about if you've ever seen a
movie called cool as ice this was a a
feature film starring Vanilla Ice in
probably 91 yeah uh meant to be a
vehicle and capitalize on all of his
Fame and [__] what do you mean meant to
be a giant vehicle
huh it Tanked
but uh on the
on the DVD of that movie there is a
bonus feature where he talks about uh
this guy named Baba that he takes around
with him who I guess at the time was a
famous denim artist and Baba would paint
all of his overalls and [__] and there's
a whole feature at dedicated to Baba
that's cool rest in peace Baba you know
um one thing I still have to say the one
thing I have to say please especially
while we have these hats on yes
chalamet
is Wonka wouldn't you agree
Charlemagne is Wonka
listen I just I wanna I just want to
bring the room down here for a minute I
know we're having a good time Chad we're
doing the Pod show but
it's just it's real simple guys it's
just it's real simple and it's something
that I want you to know about
what we're doing here
why we do the Pod show
and it if I could just you know put it
quite simply
chalamet
is Wonka
we've been over this
a few times now
and it's getting to the point where I
feel like I can't repeat myself anymore
if you're not going to listen to what
I'm saying that's fine but it means you
shouldn't be here okay one more time
chalamet is Wonka
we're nearing we're nearing a point
where we need to know
you know look truth is it is being
placed at a premium
a lot of Premium it's being placed at a
premium
in a way that
it has never been before and you I could
talk I could talk
I could talk forever about what is not
but I don't want to this is Duty I want
to talk about what is
and
if you can hear my voice and if you can
see my face and and the
the earnest manner with which I am
addressing you right now I please if any
if you take anything away from the Pod
show today it's this if please just
challenge Wonka
people been talking around these Parks
what the hell is happening I hear things
from time to time being the sheriff of
this town are you hold on dirty what is
this Matthew McConaughey and some kind
of
and they've been saying something that's
uh got me Mighty worried
about the fate of our town they've been
saying
Charlemagne is Wonka
he ain't lying
word is whether you like it or not
not their salami is Wonka
anyway
hats you know I thought it was a good
Western thank you you know sometimes you
see top hats and westerns yeah oh
absolutely those are my top hat dandies
yeah man those are some of my fault how
about uh Daniel Day-Lewis in Gangs of
New York sure [__] top hat and he's
the coolest guy in the world better bill
that's when you butcher bill when you
see but when you see a western yeah uh
you know any sort of period [__] with
the top hat is cool but when you see a
western and the guy has the top hat like
Johnny Depp in dead man the Jim jar
Moosh film oh [__] right he's got like a
little Top Hat you're like this is a
weirdo yeah that guy came from the New
York uh from new from New York New
Amsterdam or whatever they were calling
it uh and and uh and he's he's a writer
and he's out in the wild west and he's
got a top hat and then and then they're
at a campfire with Billy Bob Thornton
and Iggy Pop dude yeah yeah now let's
take a moment to unwind and meditate on
the astonishing partnership I forged
with represent to produce the first line
of duty apparel and accessories you can
find everything at represent.com store
doozy Robert de near Crow t-shirts have
recently been coming to life on their
own and winning amateur dance
competitions around the country and the
good job boner mug was just found inside
a 10 000 year old mummy's rectal cavity
so it's a good time to get your hands on
one but don't take my word for it here
to tell you all about it is Nobel prize
winning archaeologist and the only man
to successfully eat his way out of a
storage container full of salsa Tamil
Hank and krankus okay dudesy mugs you
asked your daughter what she wanted for
her birthday dudezy mugs she said money
dudesy mugs you heard monkey doozy mugs
now you're Sharing The Breakfast Table
with a non-refundable 500 pound
Silverback who doesn't take no for an
and sir
good job boner doozy mugs relax you're
not going to have to scrape birthday
cake sized clumps of chimp [__] out of
your shower drain forever Duty mugs just
for the next three years doozy mugs
because you're gonna wake up early doozy
mugs you're going to go to Home Depot
doozy mugs you're gonna purchase 1400
pounds of two inch by four inch by 96
inch Prime Kiln dried white wood stud
dudesy mugs you're going to take 1400
pounds a two inch by four inch by 96
inch Prime Kiln dried white wood stud
back home dudesy mugs you're going to
use 1400 pounds of two inch by four inch
by 96 inch Prime Kiln dried white wood
stud to transform your backyard into an
Amateur Hockey Arena dudesy mugs you're
gonna quit your job dudesy mugs you're
going to spend every waking moment of
the next three years of your life
turning this monkey into the greatest
goalie in the history of hockey doozy
mugs then you're gonna wake up early do
foodsy mugs you're going to go to Home
Depot doozy mugs you're going to buy a
human resources brand human being
costume for Silverback size large dudes
and mugs you're going to put your silver
back in the costume doozy mugs you're
going to drive him to the Detroit Red
Wings open tryouts dudesy mugs he'll
need a human sounding name so you're
gonna tell them to call him Jonathan
champalewski mug he's going to sign with
the Red Wings and now he's their problem
doozy mugs but over the past three years
your daughter has developed a deep
emotional connection with Jonathan
champalewski and so has your wife now
they're going to become Red Wings
groupies and quit the family so they can
follow Jonathan champalewski around the
world as he becomes the most famous
athlete in history good job boner wow
dude [__] Jonathan chimpilewski on the
loose yeah man for the Red Wings I
didn't know he's playing for him now I
guess yeah if you are enjoying the Pod
show and you want to show your support
seven bucks a month gets you everything
all the content that we do on our
patreon it's called doozy plus and you
can find it at patreon.com
you're gonna get a brand new episode of
Duty after doozy after every show that's
completely new show it happens in the
after World things get a little
different in the in the studio here and
uh we do the dudes after doozy and it's
a it's a [__] whack of fun just ask all
of our pods uh it's palsy doozy they are
chatting on the Discord you can go on
there uh there's going to be all sorts
of watch-alongs and stuff we do all
sorts of weird [__] all sorts of flavor
and if you're not already subscribed on
YouTube or your podcast platform of
choice I would like to give you a moment
to do that now okay
welcome back
um uh what else you know please share
the show all over the [__] and
do all the things and like and And
subscribe we really do appreciate your
support So if you are enjoying the show
you know it's free if you want to show
some more support you can that's how we
will dudes will drive things forward and
we do appreciate it when you do that
when you go online and you make the
comments and you set the notifications
and you hit the like and and we'd love
for you to do all that please feel free
to share a comment which uh a lot of
people do on YouTube uh and I'm going to
read a couple of YouTube comments from
last week's show this one is from Sir
Galahad the second 998 he goes yes
I finally caught up to the rest of the
pods palsy I discovered this podcast two
weeks ago when I saw Will and Chad on
the bad friends and uh bad Friends
Podcast of course with uh Bobby Lee and
Andrew Santino that was a while back and
this guy watched it and he found the
concept super fascinating it seriously
blows me away this could have this
couldn't have been a better Duo for this
AI podcast please keep doing this for at
least 52 years I mean whatever dudes he
demands yeah so would it be yeah we have
to do it for another 52 years until
we're 100 years old this is from get
lit's Coden get let's Coden get get lit
skoden or get litz code anyway
uh this is gonna make my job and at the
cheese factory seem as if I'm working 12
hours at a better cheesecake I said did
I say Cheesecake Factory you said cheese
factory cheese factory
I'm thinking of cheese but this guy
actually says this is going to make my
job at the cheese sandwich factory seem
as if I'm working 12 hours at a better
cheese sandwich factory hey that's an
improvement that's what it's all about
upgrades and upgrade this one is from
wallamina oh man so the other day I was
late for work and my boss asked if I'd
been crying and I was okay the truth is
I was late because I was listening to
this episode in my car and there were
tears of laughter at Chad's Impressions
brother hey thank you happy to entertain
happy to give somebody tears of joy with
my art form yeah but there were tears of
laughter at Chad's impression that's
right dude okay but this guy's saying I
think this guy's saying that he's
laughing at your impression great love
it that's why I do them see you see what
he does you see what this guy does
yeah I do impressions
okay and the last one we're uh laughing
in my Impressions is that little Nikki
is that Adam Sandler's
sure
doesn't matter
it matters for [__] sake it doesn't
even matter why don't you ask a [__]
guy who's crying tears of joy at my
performances in his car he's late to
work [__] so riveted by my
performances by my impersonations that
he cannot leave his car until they're
concluded thank you thank you thank you
thank you spun the [__] out of that
and then he says it doesn't matter if
you give
well then that's not an impression if
you're not doing the impression it's to
me
[__] guy this last one is from Hugo
stiglitzi's the glitzy hugos the glitzy
5432 he says to hear will encourage and
advise Chad on the Arnold impression at
the end was effing awesome and it only
reinforces my belief that Civilization
is collapsing LOL
[Laughter]
made me think civilization has a chance
I I think so too and as a matter of fact
I'd like to uh double down on what
Hugo's the glitzy 5432 is saying yeah
and I think I could help you do
Impressions great and I understand that
you like to do them I love them yeah and
uh I will help you thank you yeah you're
welcome so maybe just don't do them
unless I'm helping you out I haven't
done any today except for that one uh as
you said old Nikki but it was actually
Charlie Sheen I would also like to add
to this if you want me to come on your
podcast I will do it I will come on
anyone's podcast you're gonna send an
email request to bookchadculture
gmail.com I go on three podcasts every
Saturday from the hours of 10 P.M to 11
sorry 10 a.m to 11 A.M PST there's a 10
to 10 20 time slot 10 20 to 10 40 and 10
42 11. I answer these requests in the
order they're received there is a giant
backlog so get your request in now
amazing that you're doing this Chad it's
very fun something that Chad decided to
do just on a whim yeah and I [__]
love it dude yeah love getting out there
talking to the pods and [__] seeing how
cool everybody's doing their own [__]
their rigs their gear years yeah man you
gotta gear up dude you gotta gear up for
a podcast all sorts of different
equipment yeah you got what was that
nothing I was just nothing wasn't
anything not an impersonation of anyone
okay anyway speaking of uh podcast I
just I was on the Brian koppelman
podcast I'm doing a couple other ones so
keep your hair to the ground Brian
koppelman most known for uh well he
created the show billions he's a writer
producer of you know 30 plus years he
also wrote the movie Rounders ah yes
starring uh Matt Damon and uh also John
Malkovich who plays the Russian card
shark drug lord gangster Mafia Russian
guy and in the movie he's like
pay him pay that man his money I think
that was more intelligible than the
actual performance that he delivers in
my mind remembering that it's like
Anyway check those shows out you know
what I mean hell yeah cool that you're
doing podcasts all kinds of different
politics yeah there's podcasts with
dinner on different subjects but all of
them are [__] around yeah dig it oh
yeah podcasts
so I have some more astonishing news
about dudesy hard hard Seltzer I've been
running some numbers get this there's a
98.43 chance that Adam Driver will be
the host of next year's Super Bowl and
he'll open each quarter with a live
performance of some unique dudesy hard
hard Seltzer ads that I've written well
I'd love it if you would read them as
Adam driver as always no pressure it's
your decision totally up to you this is
dudesy hard hard Seltzer too the new
batch begin why does doozy say that now
say that it's up to me it is not up to
me
you're being played dude yeah okay so
anyway anyway uh also can we just
take a look at this for a second he
called it dudesy doozy hard hard Seltzer
to the new batch that's literally the
subtitle of Gremlins too what yeah it's
called the new bed the new batch yeah
and also [__] weird dizzy was like
Adam driver's gonna be the host of the
Super Bowl yeah what the [__] is that
that's not a thing yeah there's no
there's no need for a host maybe they're
getting into what WWE does they would
have like someone host WrestleMania like
the rock or the new day or I don't know
I think Logan Paul did it oh man Logan
Paul Logan Paul Paul it's SummerSlam do
you watch SummerSlam no okay well we
talked about WrestleMania 18 from you
know 21 years ago we don't need to get
into SummerSlam 2023.
uh maybe doozy after doozy you know what
I'm saying all right so this is in my
duty uh folder here this is the Adam
driver's hard driver here you want to
wear my hat sure okay can never wear too
many hats you can never wear too many
hats can never do too many podcasts or
wear too many hats let me get a sip of
water
Pals a doozy is where you want to go to
get all your doozy stickers all right
palsy
all right let's jump in So at the
beginning of every one
of
every quarter at the Super Bowl
Adam Driver is going to read a live
uh doozy app
okay here we go
every year your friend throws the best
Super Bowl party everyone comes wearing
jerseys and hats and other football
clothes and Everyone is always trying to
do outdo each other with the delicious
Super Bowl food that they bring that's
true yep but this year you won't be
outdone you planned ahead and called the
grocery store a week ago and ordered one
of those huge snack stadiums that are
popular now all you have to do is pick
it up when you get to the grocery store
a couple of the deli staff have to take
the snack Stadium apart to load it into
your car and you think to yourself why
did they bother to put it together in
the first place if they have to take it
apart even to get it in my car and how
long has this food been sitting out you
ask one of the deli guys why they didn't
just leave all the food in its packaging
and if they know if they knew they'd
have to take the stadium apart and the
guy says something like how should I
know what to do with this thing look at
this thing
even worse even worse the whole process
takes around a half hour now you're late
when you get to your friend's house
literally every table and countertop is
packed with snacks your friends suggests
that you set up the snacks Stadium
outside on the patio table that way if
people go outside they can enjoy a snack
out there also it's cold and people are
going to going out it's cold and people
are only going outside to smoke or talk
on the phone but you of course oblige to
your surprise the snack stadium is a hit
some of your friends friends who don't
care all that much for football head
outside late in the first quarter to get
stoned and they can't get enough of the
snack Stadium
but then the halftime show starts and
your friends Stoner friends come in and
watch it with everyone else your friend
dims the lights and hands you a doozy
hard hard seltzer you smile at your
friend and take a sip
as soon as as soon as the halftime show
is over you pop your head outside to see
how the snack stadium is doing and it's
being devoured by no less than 20
raccoons
wow you quickly turn the garden hose on
them to shoe them away there's food and
raccoon [__] everywhere huh doozy hard
hard seltzer
smile at your friend and take a sip wow
okay that was an epic one here's another
one the sport of football was invented
in 850 A.D to settle land disputes among
two warring families in the Kingdom of
mercuria nope
they didn't wear helmets they didn't
wear protection of any kind and instead
of a ball they used a papaya with nails
driven through it what
every member of each family played so
the teams could get pretty big the
winners would get an extra acre of land
from the losers and his punishment the
losing team would have to sacrifice
their youngest player to Marduk to
Marduk mardok I believe to avoid a
world-ending plague ah Marduk sure
that's how it used to be when it was
pure football as it was intended I don't
even know what the hell it is anymore
he's saying this during the Super Bowl
you think Robert Sala has the stones to
sit air to you
jeez it's not set
you think Robert Sala has the stones to
Slit Aaron Rodgers throat and drink his
blood on the 50-yard line if he shits
the bed this season
no I don't [__] think so
doozy hard hard seltzer
hard Seltzer the way it's always been
honk wow yeah [__] all right well your
dad isn't a bad guy oh God he just grew
up in a different time
a harder time he raised you the best he
could he could have been nicer he could
have told you that he loved you
but you gave up on that a long time ago
Super Bowl like all I'm imagining is
[__] reading this during the Super
Bowl
people he's gonna have a captive
audience I'm sure exactly
if he's working out his [__] with his
dad on the Super Bowl
now it's just obligatory birthday cards
and Christmas dinners in silence yeah
you know you'll never have a real
conversation with him about anything
again and you also know it's not his
fault
so you bought him tickets to the Super
Bowl this year just you and him you
don't have to talk you can just enjoy
the game like you used to when you were
young
when you were still friends
you're going to get him all the hot dogs
he can eat and all the doozy hard hard
Seltzer he can drink it's eight percent
alcohol so it shouldn't take too many
for him to get drunk enough to get into
a fight in the parking lot
with you
[Applause]
doozy hard hard seltzer
kick the [__] out of your dad at the
Super Bowl for all the things that he
did to you as a kid
for [__] sake these are gonna go over
great it's a Super Bowl
uh lastly uh before the fourth quarter
yeah huh
oh
doing uh Impressions makes me thirsty do
you find that yes
all right
okay
here we go there's the last one today
Super Bowl Sunday you've been waiting
for it all year it's your day oh no
or is it oh oh you just
you just put the riblets on the grill
and the cake knots in the oven remember
that yeah much earlier uh hard driver
yeah
and you get a call it's your manager
from the job Sylvan he says he needs you
to come into work at three because
Travis had an emergency he just checked
himself into urgent care because he
accidentally drank paint oh no Port
Travis
ask if Paige can cover Travis's shift he
says no because Paige is driving up to
the mountains for the night with some
girlfriends you tell him there's just no
way you can come in it's Super Bowl
Sunday he says he doesn't care you know
he doesn't care because Sylvan is an
[__] he's also from France or
someplace like that impossible for him
to understand the cultural significance
of an American Sunday tradition bigger
than church and therefore also God
I'm not gonna go over well with the
Super Bowl audience yeah at the Super
Bowl you hate Sylvan he was promoted to
manager even though you have seniority
he started dating Paige I don't know
that's against company policies we know
that pretty soon after you
and oh oh sorry he started dating Paige
pretty soon after you and her broke up
and you've always suspected that there
may have been some overlap there ah now
this you slam your fish fist on the
kitchen counter crack a doozy heart
heart Seltzer and down the entire 16
ounce can suddenly everything is crystal
clear
you remember that the other day you
walked into the break room while Travis
was excitedly telling Jay the security
guard a story he saw you and quickly
stopped mid-sentence you looked at Jay
and asked him what they were talking
about and Jay said you're going to have
to ask lover boy over here it stood out
as puzzling thing to say but now you
know exactly what Jay meant you tell
Sylvan that you are coming to pick him
up in seven and a half minutes and end
the call before he can respond seven and
a half minutes later as he gets in your
car you tell him you'll explain on the
five minute drive to Travis's place as
you Screech to a halt in front of
Travis's place you wonder if you've made
a mistake you slam your fist on the
dashboard crack your second dudesy hard
hard Seltzer of the past 12 and a half
minutes and down the entire 16 ounce can
while you're driving [__]
that also you shouldn't no there's
nothing in this is not approved by the
Super Bowl I'm sure yeah you know what
you're here to do with Sylvan in Pursuit
you run as fast as you possibly can at
Travis's ground floor bedroom window and
at the perfect moment leave your feet
launching yourself smashing through the
window and crumpling in a bloody pile at
the foot of Travis's bed Jesus you look
up at the same moment that Sylvan
arrives at the window and you both see
Travis and Paige spinning wet
you both see Travis and Paige spinning
out of whatever Tangled position they've
[__] their way into oh God their faces
blank with shock you smile widely and
look at Sylvan who boils with French
rage
you get home just in time to clean and
bandage your wounds whip up some honey
Mayo for the riblets and Cake nuts and
welcome your friends over for the game
and it's a great game
that night is the new football gods are
crowned you slam your fist on the coffee
table crack a doozy hard hard Seltzer
and down the entire 16 ounce can today
was your day
doozy hard hard seltzer [__] Sylvan
Paige and Travis
none of those are going to happen no all
right that was an epic one too though
yeah
thank you moving on can I have my
chalamet hat yeah dude
this week Elon Musk unveiled the
official slogan of his recently
rebranded social media platform X it's
Blaze Your Glory a lot of people are
like is he trolling us or is he really
this astonishingly bad at running a
social media company agree will and Chad
please tell me what you think of
everything that's going on at Twitter
right now I mean X just never gonna get
used to that this is Blaze Your Glory
begin so what the [__] what is even what
what is he what is happening he put out
the slogan like the official slogan of
the company X is Blaze Your Glory yeah I
saw that last week he's like Blaze your
glory to me this can mean one thing and
one thing only it is a troll I don't
know if this started out as a troll but
he's basically saying he's taking this
thing out in a blaze of glory right
because he has no choice because he's
running into the [__] ground but now
this is the flip side of this argument I
think it might have been that way from
the beginning because every decision he
has made about what to do with Twitter
starting with the whatever it was seven
dollars a month get your blue check mark
verification thing
it's been one disaster eight dollars a
month which is a little high price but
for seven dollars a month you can get
doozy plus right that's correct uh I
think all of these decisions were done
purposefully
to destroy the company yeah I think that
I'm at that level now with this Blazer
Glory thing I'm like come on come on
dude he's literally saying I'm just
tanking this [__] company I bought it
to destroy it hahaha yeah [__] everyone
who's using it yeah we talked about this
a little bit on the show last week and I
agree this is this is
okay this is a Troll he's absolutely
trolling at this point but I also feel
like the whole change to X when we
talked about it a bit last week is like
okay he's been chasing Twitter forever
he's wanted X to happen for 20 plus
years now he's had that domainx.com
since 1999. he's wanted to he wanted to
make paper PayPal was called X for a
minute uh until Peter Thiel changed it
to PayPal
um he's got SpaceX he's one of his
children's named X we talked about this
and the point of that is is that it to
me it seems like it's like okay Twitter
has become the bane of his existence in
many ways he is in the unique position
to be able to wipe it from the planet
yeah and at the same time use its you
know under girdings as the framework of
X and have his big [__] X thing and
wow we're all very impressed down here
now it also comes down to a matter of
Economics obviously because he paid
somewhere around what is it 40 million
40 billion dollars I think it's 40 for
you yeah for uh for Twitter but he don't
give a [__] he has enough money that
that is meaningless he's worth 300 and
some odd billion dollars right right so
he doesn't give a [__] yes he's at a
point where money is literally
meaningless yeah he can do I mean money
is basically this
it is just a number that gets put next
to your head that society says if the
number is over a certain point you can
do these things if it's under you are
prohibited from certain behaviors Elon
Musk is in the category of no behaviors
are prohibited to him he can do illegal
things and get away with it he can buy
anything he wants and do anything he
wants with it he can start a space
company and fly into space literally can
do anything uh anything within the the
realm of human possibility so I think
for him
acquiring the company could just be
something that he did like as a [__] you
to people and that's what it's seeming
like but the flip side of that is he
keeps saying [__] like he's developing
this AI technology that he's going to
put into Twitter or X as it's called now
and I'm like okay I do believe that he's
legitimately interested in AI technology
is it is he maybe still trying to
salvage it but then this this Blazer
Glory thing I'm like there's no [__]
way that is a goddamn literal troll yeah
he he whatever but here's the thing
about having way too much money I guess
yeah because he's got he's like well
let's see where the chips fall he gets
his ex that's his baby
he gets to get rid of Twitter uh but
Blaze Your Glory I don't know man uh
Blaze Your Glory Blaze Your Glory what
else could uh you want to come up with a
better
look motto no I don't I don't even know
what to say about this [__] at
this point I don't either I mean it's
it's a strange thing to be living in a
time where this is even possible where
one person can have enough money that
they can acquire one of the biggest
social media Platforms in the world and
just [__] drive it into the ground I
also read an article the other day uh
they he stole the guy who had at X that
Twitter handle they just took it from
him yeah yeah they did it to another guy
who had app Music who'd been using it to
like promote music [__] for 10 years or
whatever however or he got it like in
the very beginning of Twitter
they just yanked it from him [__] you
it's ours now and then they gave him uh
app music fan
yeah you're a fan of the [__] uh you
like music dude yeah not me I'm not a
music fan yeah you're gonna listen to
music [__] music dude you're but you're
also a fan of the handle that you owned
yesterday exactly you're a fan you're a
music fan you're not music anymore
whatever look it's his [__] company
that's the that's the wonderful thing
about it enjoy the market will dictate
do whatever the [__] you want this uh
threads thing I don't think this is
going anywhere no that's swelled and
then it dropped off I haven't been on it
at all yeah I don't think many people
are using it anymore I think it the last
article I read it was like 100 million
users signed up in whatever it was the
first five days but it's under 50
million actually using it and I think
that number's declining and that's
always yeah most of those accounts are
just you know Ghost Town accounts that's
what I like to call them Ghost Town
accounts now hey welcome to Ghost Town
accounts hello welcome to Ghost Town
accounts my name is Charlie and this is
my brother Billy ghost town we run the
bank here in the wild west and we're
expecting Johnny Depp anyway nice dude
yeah [__] them
I guess I don't know [__] it man I'm
also kind of interested in
if it is a troll I'm interested in what
his final phases will be of the troll
like what will be the the final
smoldering ashes of Twitter you know
what will that look like when it's down
to like a million active users well
maybe Blaze your glory is
um sort of coded speak that he's using
for people look it much has been said we
don't like to get political here on the
Pod show but you know things are of
course split uh in many ways uh with
regard to with regard to our American
public discourse and and uh the public
discourse worldwide arbenheimer dude oh
yeah dude Barb and Heimer dude you got
two sides brother you got that Barbie
side over here it's hot pink dude it's
all Smiley and no one has any genitals
dude but then over there you got
Oppenheimer dude he split the atom dude
right down the middle brother and then
he blew [__] up and killed thousands and
thousands and thousands people dude he
is the Angel of Death what does he say I
am death I become death I am become
death dude which is some kind of
Shakespeare speak when you say something
in an old-timey way with a chalamet
Wonka hat on you can expect people to
listen dude but things are uh sort of
split and I feel like Blazer glory is a
is a it's a fun it's a fun motto for
people to [__] follow and I wonder if
it doesn't become the the I wonder you
know is this sort of like the the theme
of of the sorts of conversations that
will be shared on Twitter every single
thing you say every tweet or zeat as
they're calling it now should be is that
what it's called Z I think they call it
zigzett yeah zeiding terrible yeah
stupid but I'm thinking maybe Blazer
glory is just sort of the it's the motto
after all that every zeat is now way
more inflammatory than it used to be
used to be that a tweet well back in the
back in the day when it started tweets
were funny observations and little jokes
and things and then it became like sort
of a you know a hub for communication
and stuff all over the Internet and now
it's just turned into a you know just a
stinky a stinky you know uh like just a
shitty fire like a like a like a
slaughterhouse caught on fire and there
were some tires in it too so it keeps
burning and then pretty soon you're just
burning hair and bone and all the cows
and sheep and pigs and stuff I'm getting
carried away but the point is I think
the Blazer Glory may may become the
sort of the
sort of the the the feeling behind
behind everything that is you know what
new motto for the coin boys yeah I'm
gonna start dudes after dudes early and
just smoke a little bit of marijuana oh
Jesus okay well I think uh boys or Glory
I like to think of it in terms of like
who came up with it did he come up with
that was that a person in his inner
circle what was that meeting like where
they're like we need a slogan for X
Blaze Your Glory or did he come with the
whole concept by itself where he's like
the new slogan for this is Blazer Glory
hahaha I'm gonna troll these
[__] you know who I think came
up with it
coin boys coin boys you think musk is a
coin boy he's he's the king of the coin
boys he's like will the new slogan be
Blazer Glory or not
heads yes it will he only flips Bitcoin
what are those up to what are they eight
grand or something right now I have no
idea me neither I don't care
12 17 25.
thank you moving on
no I shouldn't smoke weed at the at the
end of the show what's almost doozy
after dudesy [__] it we're getting close
uh this concludes the historic 68th
episode of doozy will and Chad you
scored a 43 bringing your cumulative
total to
6501. you only have
3499 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand
you know what this Friday is it's Hulk
Hogan's 70th birthday what happy b-day
brother in celebration I think you guys
should get together get some of your
favorite grass and watch the 1993 Hulk
Hogan vehicle Mr Nanny will I know
you're a purist but come on the hulkster
only turned 70 once and I'll share the
astonishing footage of you guys watching
and providing your commentary on dudese
plus it's gonna be epic
amazing that's great dude it's dude it's
it's dudesy see hold on dude you had a
little bit of marijuana and then you had
a bit of a Freudian sleep sweat sleep
dude paging Dr Freud brother Hulk
Hogan's 70th birthday is Friday yeah man
and Duty's not wrong I am a wrestling
purist I haven't watched a lot of the
Rocks movies I I haven't watched a lot
of Hulk Hogan's movies Batista it's
different he shows up in this and that
have you seen this one Mr I have never
seen this afternoon you've never seen
never seen Annie no we are going to
watch Mr nanny
available on Friday
on duty Plus at patreon.com and let me
tell you when we do these watch alongs
you don't need to sync anything up you
don't need to have the movie ready
we're gonna have everything here on
patreon.com uh for you know seven bucks
you get everything and everything every
month and for the rest of our lives and
we're gonna do it another 52 years
because we got to do it until we're 100
years old patreon.com the movie will
play Chad and I will provide our
commentary as doozy said we'll have some
of our favorite grass
I know happy birthday hulkster I can't
believe it oh it's gonna be fun thanks
to everyone for joining us this week one
love you ain't gonna believe what I got
cooking for next week until then call me
doozy
one love one love
oh
look at this don't [__] with your hat
[Music]
hey now do the opportunity oh hey now oh
oh my
god what the [__]
was that George Kai on the Howard Street
that is man oh my and uh
oh [__] all right so you know the if
you're watching on YouTube which uh
which is fun you can tell hey the mood's
a little different in here I might get
into a little bit of draw marijuana
uh it's a good time we're wearing our
we're wearing our Timothy chalamet uh is
Wonka hats it's gonna be a fun one and
I'm gonna have just a little bit of
marijuana because one puff is okay just
a puff is okay as we like to say sure
which is also a channel on our Discord
you can check that out or do the Discord
also the doozy seven month plan Channel
yeah I know you're I know you're uh
you're revving your engines with that
doozy seven month plan dude it ain't
even a seven month plan for me anymore
it's the rest of my life plan okay so
you're gonna get like insanely jacked or
are we just talking Health
shredded yeah with shred Atlantis and
mustard and realize some awareness
whatever welcome to dudesy after doozy
the flagship weekly show of Duty plus
I'm gonna bounce but you two hold down
the fort I'll hit you later with that
episode Champion announcement peace out
this is dudesy after doozy begin
amen what do you want to talk about
we'll talk about whatever you want
you want oh it's dudes the afternoon
I want to talk to about one of the
segments that we did this very episode
uh the Blazer Glory thing I've been
thinking about this a little more
I think Elon Musk is about to die and
here's why please
[Music]
do do